on today's show we're going to be
talking about how to talk to your kids
about gender transitions and gender
identity changes within your family
we're going to be talking with a newly
married woman
who does not like her husband's ex-wife
and we're going to be talking to a young
man in texas
who struggled after the death of his
father and wants to reconnect with his
sisters
stay tuned
[Music]
hey good folks i'm john and this is the
dr john deloney show
a live show where we show up and walk
alongside people who are struggling
folks who are trying to do the next
right thing and fellow humans who are
learning how to be human beings again
we talk about it all on the show
anything and everything no matter what's
going on in your heart your mind your
family
or your country and there's a lot going
on in the country
whatever's going on we're here to walk
with you and here's the thing
you're not alone people are having the
same thoughts the same questions the
same concerns
right we're gonna talk about falling in
and out of love we're gonna talk about
loss
family issues infidelity grinding and
scratching and clawing for hope
and we may talk about cities that have
the slogan
keep our city weird keep our city weird
here's the deal
if you ever have to call a meeting to
talk about how cool it is that you are
weird
or if you ever have to call a meeting to
talk about printing bumper stickers
to let the world know how weird you or
your city are
you by definition are not weird you're
annoying
you're an idiot right if you have to
announce you are weird
you are not weird you're desperate truly
weird people
or weird cities or weird towns they're
labeled that by other people
when they aren't in the room right true
glorious shape-shifting
weirdos is just unaware of itself it
just makes its way through the world
in all of its beautiful lovely weirdness
it just is and so if you ever think i
live in a town and our slogan is keep
ourselves weird
go to your city council and change that
and say keep us less desperate
keep us relatively normal relatively
um whack-a-doodle-doo i don't care
whatever you call it but seriously don't
go in a room and have
weird as a sales label for yourself or
for your city so whatever's going on
your home your heart your head
i'm here to get weird with you give me a
call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291
or you can email me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
that's ask john ramseysolutions.com
all right let's go straight to the
phones today let's start with
let's go to erin in lansing michigan
aaron good morning how are we doing
good how are you good it is super early
in michigan huh
um i mean it's not i've i've been awake
for a while so it's not that bad
nine o'clock is still late for some
james or early for some yeah
all right so uh what's going on aaron
how can i help
um so my sister is moving back
home um from philadelphia and she
is transitioning and i don't know how to
tell
how to talk to my eight-year-old son
about that okay i don't know how to kind
of support her but
shelter him um okay so
oh i feel kind of stuck tell me about
the the journey here how have you been a
part of this walking this with
your sister and what is moving home back
mean walk me through what all these
things mean
um well i kind of had i kind of
keep my distance a little bit um she had
lived
near us like we're all very tight family
in the same town
and then she went to philadelphia to be
a missionary for a year
and then started taking testosterone to
transition okay
um one quick second aaron for those
listening
um for those who say someone is
transitioning that means they
are from a woman to a man right
so they're going to transition their
gender from one to another
yeah and is is she's been taking
hormones and i'm assuming she's been
working with folks and so she gonna have
gender reassignment surgery
i i think so in the future but i don't
think we're there quite yet
okay but she also has like bpd and
um schizophrenia so she's coming home to
get help with that
too okay so i just kind of feel like
that's a lot to
i don't know if i should just stay away
that's not very supportive
yeah so when you say stay away versus be
supportive walk me through what that
means
oh i don't know maybe just like keeping
the distance so there's
peace and no uncomfortableness or
arguments i guess that's not really
how a family works but yeah i don't know
many families that don't have
don't have arguments do you have
brothers and sisters mom and dad still
in the picture
my mom yeah our dad um committed suicide
when my sister was like nine
so i that was some of the early trauma
that she had
um and then i have another sister and
brother and we all live like within a
couple blocks of each other once
she gets home so and so when your sister
moves home
is your sister gonna be living with your
mom yeah
and what does help look like for
schizophrenia and the bipolar
um seeing the specialist for that the
i don't remember what it's called um not
a psychiatrist for the people
with the brain specialties like a
neurologist
yeah yeah okay but she's getting medical
care basically
yeah she will be when she gets here yeah
okay and where is she living now
philadelphia so she actually comes home
this weekend okay
so here's um there's two separate things
here
number one and i hear you asking two
separate questions one is what you do
and one how do you talk to your
eight-year-old right
yeah so if i'm you um
i would be there when
my sister comes home and i would be
there
with the biggest
strongest hug i could possibly muster
and i would be there to greet them
with is as much love as i have capacity
to put forth
and that is not a judgment on the mental
health issues that's not
a judgment or indictment on the gender
transition
none of that that is i'm your sister
and i love you and we've all been
through a lot as a family
and my guess is you and i could probably
talk for a couple hours and unpack
a just a history right
of of ups and downs and challenges your
family's endured
and at the end of the day my default
setting is always going to be love
always if you feel that you're unsafe
if the bipolar and the schizophrenia
puts you or your kid
or your family in a position where you
all are safe then of course you've got
to draw some pretty firm boundaries
i also know that living with or
in relationship with someone who is
acutely bipolar or acutely schizophrenic
by the way
those two diagnostics don't work
together so somebody somewhere
hopefully she'll get better care
i think the last i looked those two
can't be comorbid which means they can't
be co-occurring psychiatric issues
um i may need to get somebody write me
in if i'm wrong on that but i think i'm
right there
um but they are commonly just when
psychiatrists are throwing stuff up
against the wall but hopefully she'll
get the the psychiatric care she needs
if you ever feel unsafe of course draw
those boundaries
um but i think your heart will struggle
with
just cutting your sister out
and leaving your mom to just figure it
out
and i may be wrong there but that's what
i'm getting from your heart
as it relates to your eight-year-old
tell me about your eight-year-old
um i don't know he's awesome and right
now he just knows that um
she i just said she has a nickname so
i don't know why sometimes people want
nicknames so we'll just call her this
okay um so is she asking the family to
refer to her by a new name
oh yeah yeah okay walk me through what
that process looks like for your family
um or what is your sister requested of
of the family
oh to just completely accept her as this
new
person right and so her and i have had
some
tough conversations yeah about me not
being ready to talk to my son about it
okay and that's bringing up tears in
your heart tell me about that
no i don't know i just feel bad
that she's gone through so much trauma
and i want her to get
help for that and i don't necessarily i
don't agree that this is
the way that you fix it gotcha
and so here's here's um
you've got um um let me let me
back out a little bit i think that i
want you to honor let me say this way
i want you to honor and mourn um
the transition of your sister you had a
picture of your sister
you had dreams for your sister you know
she's been through
a nightmarish childhood and regardless
of what you think about
gender transition surgeries right you
know somebody who is
is going down that path is struggling
with who they are who they've been
where they want to go who they see in
the mirror who has loved them who hasn't
loved them and that's a nightmare for
anybody to walk forget the morality of
it and forget the politics of it and
forget the
the all the stuff that surrounds that
nobody wishes that journey on anybody
because it's a nightmare
right i've sat with too many students
and too many people in that world
and so you ache for your sister you
mourn for your sister and
i want you to honor that okay and i
don't know if you spent some time by
yourself
or with someone that you care about just
crying over the
pain for your sister but i think that's
worthy of being done
okay that just shows you care about your
sister okay yeah
yeah um as for your eight-year-old um
here's i actually i knew this particular
call was common
and so i i i don't have a lot of
expertise working with
kids in this situation i've got a lot of
opinions and i've got a lot of
um my own biases and
things that i lean towards but i didn't
have a lot of expertise and so i called
a couple of uh therapists who work with
kids
and got their insights and here is
here's a really a direct approach that
and it's important to remember a couple
of things about eight-year-olds and also
um to remember something between about
eight-year-olds
y'alls two relationship the first thing
is is kids don't carry
um i don't wanna say baggage but that's
the word i'm gonna use here they don't
carry the baggage they don't understand
the political fervor around things they
don't understand the historical issues
here
um he just knows that i'm just going to
make up names here
he just knows that aunt becky now is
asked to be called
uncle steve right and there's sometimes
a
direct line to an eight-year-old this is
uncle steve
is is trying to to match what he feels
on the inside
with um uh what he looks like on the
outside
and so the next time we see aunt becky
he's at uh
she is asking us to call him he and
asking us to call him uncle steve
and we're just going to call him uncle
steve and you can choose to
say that's what he's asking it's going
to be confusing for us and we're going
to ask for some grace
and aunt becky is going to have to
remind us a few times
about the the new name she'd like to be
called and
um we're just going to honor that that's
one way of approaching it
and most young children will go okay
and when they see somebody new for the
first time when they see
somebody who's transitioned gender or
starting to and
maybe wearing more masculine
traditionally masculine clothes more
traditionally feminine clothes
they'll ask questions because
eight-year-olds ask questions and that's
where i ask
everybody to be mutually respectful of
each other right
and so if someone's coming to the house
and they're transitioning
understand that it's different for an
eight-year-old right the other side of
that is
you can tell your son anything you want
your son's going to pick up
what to do by you
by the conversations you have by how
tense you are
by how not tense you are by how not
welcoming you are by how welcoming you
are
and if you do not want your um
sister transitioning brother to be
around
your kid then make that value judgment
call it what it is and accept it for
what it's
for the the repercussions that it's
going to be right
and if you want to continue a
relationship while your sister gets well
while your sister continues to walk
through who she is and who she feels
like and how that interacts with past
traumas and all that um
then you're gonna have recurring
conversations with your son
i like to look at these conversations in
my house
as not as acute issues like what do we
do with this particular situation or
that particular situation but i like to
back out 30 000 feet
and let my kids know when people are
hurting
when people are struggling when people
make decisions that are different than
we in this house make
or that are the same as that we in this
house make
our default setting is love and our
default setting is you're welcome at our
table
and that's just a guiding principle in
our house and
i do give my kids permission to ask
questions i do give them permission to
have judgments they're eight and five
right or eight and four and a half
um but they're allowed to
question and allowed to wonder and
allowed to ask hard things and i'm gonna
give them the best answer i can but
that's always gonna start from a place
of hospitality and love right
so when i'm saying those things tell me
what you're thinking because i know
you've been down those roads in your own
heart and head before
um thinking when i have to be
honest with him and tell him everything
that's going on
and he'll probably understand it's
probably more of a bigger deal to me
than it is to him
i don't i think it'll be a big deal i
think uh because it's going to be so
different and so unique
and it will it will spur all kinds of
questions like you can just change that
and is that something i just didn't want
him to think about
that as ever you know i didn't want it
to make him
question who he was right and i think i
think that's when i talk about um
eight-year-olds don't have that
that type of baggage um okay
most most eight-year-olds like okay and
then he's gonna go on i've had my son
ask all kinds of different questions
from why are the our pets mating too why
are
you know what i mean you mean uh two two
two
women can get married and two and just
asking question after question
and yeah i just answer it direct and
honestly
and it's always i always brace for it
right like
oh here's the here's the sex question
and then i say
yeah and he goes okay hey let's go play
soccer and it's just
right and then he moves on this one will
be different because he he
has a reference point for aunt becky
right and that's going to be different
now
yeah and that's where it'll be your
responsibility to make sure
that your sister who's asking to be
called by a new name
is graceful especially with a young kid
right
right this is just different and if
somebody who's got bipolar and
schizophrenia is unable to
also be mutually hospitable as people
are trying to
wrap their heads around what's going on
um then that may be where someone's
gonna be ugly to your son then you
protect your son
right gotcha yeah okay um but
let me ask you this question do you want
your do you want your sister in your
life
yeah yeah you said that with hesitancy
i mean yeah it's gonna be a lot of
um adjustments and a lot of hard work
just like
but it's worth it all right i want you
to hang on to that last statement
that people are worth it and the
transgender conversation i may do
um we may do a whole show on it one day
just to kind of talk through the nuances
and the this isn't that's
and um but
i want you to hang on to that phrase
she's worth it as i was just saying i'm
sorry i interrupted myself
we often look at the transgender
conversation because it's such a third
rail and it's hard people understand on
every side of the situation
but i like to again back way out of that
conversation
people are different they make judgments
they make decisions with their bodies
with their minds with their actions that
we
absolutely disagree with we disagree
with it scientifically we disagree with
it
morally we disagree with it religiously
whatever your quote unquote
disagreements are
and i want everybody to always back out
and remember that people are worth it
people are worth it and that makes life
hard and it makes it confusing and it
makes it up and down and frustrating
and so is relationships so our brothers
and sisters so our moms and dads
and so um aaron thank you for your heart
thank you for working through this and
trying to love your sister trying to
love your son
and trying to figure out new territory
as you go
um and again you end up on two places
right
hospitality or um everybody's welcome
are going to figure that out or
i've got some value boundaries and i'm
just going to draw some lines
and we're going to live with what those
boundaries look like
and i'm not going to let you off the
hook and give you
give you the answer but i want you to
remember that last line that
that relationships are worth it um thank
you so so much for the call all right
let's go to ashley in denver colorado
ashley good morning how are we doing hi
dr delany thanks for taking my call
thank you so much for calling how can i
help i have a question for you about how
can i manage my emotions when i'm around
my husband's ex-wife
uh-oh all right tell me about it
um well fortunately their kids are in
their 20s
okay right so we don't have to do a
whole lot of
um togetherness
but when we do i am just i find myself
just
angry um and i recently figured out why
i'm so angry and it's because
you know she's just constantly making
comments um belittling my husband and
putting him down
so why do you give her that kind of
power
to get in your soul like that i don't
know
i don't want her there is it i don't oh
great question okay so is it
my guess is it's bigger than just
comments and snide comments
my guess is that she will always be that
other woman who had a relationship with
your husband
i'm sure that that's a that's a big part
of it does he have kids with her too
i'm sorry does he have kids with her too
they have three kids together
okay how long have you and your husband
been married
um a year and a half we've been together
for five and how long were they married
20 years 20 years so yeah you're
give yourself a break you're gonna have
a
rabid forest fire worth of jealousy
burning through you for a while
okay and um you are never going to be
able to
um all right let me say it this way
he will all she will always have 20
years worth of relationship with
the guy that you love on you does that
make sense
so if you're married to him for 20 more
years he'll have known her for 40.
right right and that's frustrating and
like like ah you know what i mean um
and at the same time the more you allow
that to take root in your heart
you're just you are intentionally
choosing to poison your marriage
right and that's that's exactly what i
don't want to do
okay um and i don't wanna i don't wanna
to get to me and i don't wanna feel that
way when we have to
be in the same room together and i don't
wanna let that in
gotcha we don't and so here's how i
handle those situations
and i wish i could give you some fancy
scientific this isn't that i'm just
gonna tell you how i handle it okay
um the first is i have worked for a
decade now
and especially the last two and a half
three years or so
to make my default setting kindness in
any situation
in any shape form or fashion with
whoever i'm talking to with whoever i'm
seeing
is i will not give other people
my character i will not give other
people my emotions i almost refuse
and now i know when it rockets out when
i just get fired up at somebody
and it happens i mean it super happens
when it does i know it's real then i
know i'm not just being petty and i'm
being a baby or whatever
right the second thing is is being
honest with yourself
you chose to marry some marry somebody
who's been married to someone else for
20 years and so
this is partly your not partly this is
almost entirely your choice to walk into
this deal
right right and so when you see her
it i was going to ask you so i won't do
that to you that would be mean
when you see her intentionally choose to
exhale and drop your shoulders down
right you go first go say hi how are you
and you can own the high ground here and
if she chooses to make well do you see
steve can you believe what he's wearing
he's always wearing those belts for 20
years he's worn those belts
um when that happens you can just smile
and say i think he looks great and then
you choose to walk away
right yeah and not letting those things
in there and dude when you walk away
your eyes are going to turn red and
you're going to get that fire
inside yourself you know what i mean
it's going to happen yeah yeah and it's
if you're not surprised by it you can
control it if you are surprised by if
your rage catches you off guard if
you're how dare you he's my man now you
know what i mean all that kind of jerry
springer stuff
if that happens then you you are
outsourcing control of your thoughts and
behaviors you're outsourcing control of
your emotions and then
then you're subject to him right so just
know it's gonna come
what does he say about it you know
what's funny is you know after this last
time i
i told him and he said well i didn't
hear what she said what did she say and
so i told him
and he said why i didn't hear it so i
don't know if he's just learned to tune
her out
you know after you know being married to
her for so long
and that he just you know there are
other things that bother him
um you know but that's those aren't it
do you feel secure in your marriage with
him absolutely
that's awesome then and if he's smart
he's gonna if he's smart when you say
can you believe what she said
in his brain he's just gonna be going
uh take a dive man just take a dive
there's that old friends episode
it's one of my favorite ever i think
rachel jennifer aniston walks out
and she's wearing something she doesn't
look great and i think she asks you know
joey
do i look good in this and chandler's
just sitting next to him and he just
goes
dude take a dive man just take a dive
and he's like trying to answer it
and so if your husband has any wisdom at
all
when you bring up her he's just going to
be like whoa
just go back into his shell and why'd i
tell you that don't put him in that
position
right i know don't put him in that
position he chose you
he chose you and he said i
am how old is he 40 50. mid-40s
okay mid-40s he's like statistically
speaking
i'm halfway or a little over halfway
there and i'm
picking i'm picking you ashley i want to
ride out this roller coaster with you
and rest in that right and just give
yourself some time you've been together
for a year and a half
and y'all are still newlyweds right
you're still newlyweds
he just has a lot more baggage in
the you know the back of his covered
wagon than you do so um
i appreciate the call give yourself some
grace and
intentionally default to kindness go
first in those relationships and then
just smile and walk away and
for god's sakes don't put your husband
in those situations
um if you just have to find someone to
vent to about his ex-wife
find a friend find a counselor find
somebody
write a letter to the editor i don't
even know if you can do that anymore can
you write letters to the editor anymore
in a paper
i don't think so i guess you can just
get on social media and thumbs down the
crap out of somebody that'll show them
um but whatever thank you so much for
that call ashley you're awesome y'all's
marriage is gonna be great
i can already tell um all right let's go
to kyle
in san antonio texas yeehaw kyle what's
up
hey dr d how's it going man good to talk
to you outstanding good to talk to you
too man
what's up so um
calling about a relationship with my two
sisters two older sisters that has gone
stale and just been scarred up pretty
bad
from uh from when my father passed away
and uh
just trying to find some help in how we
can reconcile that what i can do to
get back to where we were before then or
or just
something going forward that could be a
little a little better
man i hate that for you when's your
when's your dad pass away
that was in 2018 so uh september
2018 so it's been enough time now where
i'm kind of the person that says time
heals all wounds but
um there's still some scars there that
we're trying to recover from i know me
individually i know we all have
our own so i'm trying to i guess give
them some grace and
and understand that may be different for
everyone but um
just hasn't been where it used to be i
just look for some help in in that area
yeah so tell me what happened start with
your dad was it a sudden passing
so yes my dad was 67 it was a sudden
passing
um and he was in a different state so
literally i remember walking my young
daughters around the neighborhood
and then getting home to a text of hey
have you heard it from dad and uh
hadn't and uh man i'm so sorry and then
just all just kind of
happened really fast and so we go out
there and
and resolve um you know all that
and uh really the the issue i guess the
thing with my sisters has
had to it came down to the uh kind of
the estate
the fact that i was appointed as the
executor was oh man
um was this i guess not really a
surprise because
all three of us we had this amazing
relationship before like
um just amazing sibling relationship to
the point where
i heard about other siblings having
difficulties and i'm like how could that
be possible we have this amazing
relationship
i couldn't imagine not having a great
relationship with my sisters yeah
and um and there's also kind of a
curveball in here with
my mom who separated my dad about 15
years before then but never actually
divorced
so um we were trying to manage
relationships with each one of them
individually i would say we all had a
better relationship with my dad we all
kind of that was our home that we grew
up in
um and my dad and my mom we kind of
observed them
go through that kind of rocky marriage
and kind of
a marriage that i think we all agree
that we did not want to have
in our lives but she still has a claim
to some of that estate huh
so yes um you know just trying to
manage the whole death was already so
much and then there was just this like
legal side of everything that was
overwhelming so um
yeah it's kind of crazy i remember like
i'm like 27
28 years old and um i'm just having kids
i'm asking my dad if he has a will and
he had just made his will like i think a
year before passing which is kind of
ironic
yeah um and then and then it's kind of
one of those back of the napkin wills
and um and again i didn't think i think
he could have appointed anyone he chose
me i don't think there was any
reason between his three kids i happen
to be the youngest
um but i don't know so my guess kyle
honestly and that's
it's noble of you to try to pass that
off like he just you know picked a
random person but
um my guess is he picked you
intentionally whether he thought you
were the most mature he might have just
picked you because you were the male
and that sounds like a very texan thing
to do
and he might have done it um
trying to protect your sisters and their
pretty little heads from having to worry
about anything
and however misguided that might have
been right so it may have been noble it
may have been
um it may have been any number of
reasons why
but just to think he just randomly
picked you is is dismissive of you right
um to own it he he picked you so walk me
through what's what's happened with your
sisters why and why are they frustrated
with you why is your relationship
fractured since he passed
so the whole um the estate was not
anything special it was
you know just obviously a pretty normal
middle-class situation and then uh
but the weird thing with my mom is there
was one thing that my mom presented to
me
it was signed by my dad that said uh hey
uh
because they had split the title of the
house or whatnot it said hey
you agreed to have me be the selling
agent on the house
my mom just i guess wanted to have that
sure there's some money in there i don't
know
i don't know i don't know it was their
agreement and he had signed it they had
both signed it
so when she presented that to me i felt
obligated to honor that
just like the few other things that he
signed that you know
to me it's kind of a cut and dry like
that's not an issue so right
so i i had to tell my sisters that hey
mom's gonna
sell the house and um there's just so
much
bad blood there that they're like how
dare you his how could you not honor his
spirit how could you let that happen
he would never let her step foot in that
house blah blah blah
and so i was um i was really kind of
desperate and torn because i understand
where they're coming from but i also
kind of understand he's
in my heart like i felt that he was the
kind of guy that knew what he was doing
when he signed that and so um
so just breaking the news to them they
there was just so many
words that were said that i can never
forget along the lines of um
never going to talk to you ever again
i'm going to we're going to get our own
lawyer and
sue you um you know you're just
disgracing his
spirit and and you're you know you're
taking sides and um
and just this is a release it just
caught me so much off guard where i was
just like hey guys
he signed this thing you know you have
to understand where i'm coming from and
i was kind of just desperate for them to
understand this is so hard already like
let's not make this harder
so there was just a lot of bad words
changed
and so now i'm trying to um now we've
kind of moved on we live in separate
cities but we just don't have a
relationship
anywhere where it was before and so i'm
trying to understand is that me do i
need to reach out to them it's just not
where it is
so here's here's here's a couple of
things to to think through here okay
number one think of grief like a
um you know those big giant rubber
bouncy balls
that um you can just smash on the ground
and they'll just fly around everywhere
ping pong on off of everything
think of grief that way and you have
three siblings
all of you opened up a pantry door and
just smashed that ball in there
and it would bounce in different
trajectories for everybody
and so if your sister said some things
that were really hurtful
if they were really frustrating if they
were really just
cut you in your soul after the sudden
passing of your dad
i'm gonna tell you a hundred percent
those things hurt
they are like knives in your soul
especially when you're trying to grieve
and do the right thing
but i want you to forgive them and set
that stuff down
they were hurting in a way that they
probably had no
no way to comprehend or wrap their head
around it they're disdain for your mom
who bailed on their dad
those things get magnified when somebody
suddenly passes
then we start looking for faults and
blame and who hurt who and all that kind
of stuff and when someone just drops
dead of a heart attack
it's hard because there's there's not
much to blame there right so then
a shadowy figure emerges whose mom who
is mean to our dad
and um then it just gets messy from
there
at the end of the day those things hurt
but the more you carry them around
they're not hurting your sisters anymore
they're just hurting you and so i i
would set them down
and if you haven't my hope is you have
spent some time alone
not in the math problem of dealing with
an estate but
in the grief part of losing your old man
i hope you've spent some time actually
grieving that because that sucks
that really you know i think i have um
not yeah
and i've talked about it with my wife
and
i think it's just distracted by other
things and
i've been tried to seek out help here
and there
definitely not enough but i'm sitting
here like talking to my wife and trying
to be honest with myself and i just
don't feel like i've faced that yet
but i also feel like it's because i have
other
scars that i'm trying to dealing with
that either distract me i don't know if
i wanted to or not but yeah i'm um so
you're gonna
not disagree with you you're gonna i
think it starts tonight
or tomorrow when you're in a space and
it might you might need to tell your
wife hey i need you to take the kids
tonight
um and i want you to
um best you can write your dad a long
long letter
about the things you remember remember
about him the things you loved about him
the dude i wish you hadn't written your
will on a napkin be mad at him
um be frustrated about his marriage
and let him know why didn't you just
divorce mom that would have made this a
lot easier
um and then i want you to
spend some time writing about the man
you are
the dad you're gonna be the dad you are
the husband you are
and let him know who you're becoming
okay and i want you to be honest in this
letter and be open in this letter and if
you say ugly mean things and things spew
out of you that you didn't know were
there that's okay that's not a that's
not a black mark on his memory
um it's that's honoring him with your
authenticity
and um if you remember things that bring
you joy and make you laugh
cry that's awesome too and then
giving yourself a place that you're
going to head to next where are you
living what's the legacy that your old
man is passing through you that you'll
pass on to your kids
it's important to write that stuff down
and this won't be a one-time thing
right this won't be a oh we're all good
now right
you may want to get some guys together
from your local community from your
local church
and talk about dads do something
like that be the guy that goes first be
vulnerable right
the second thing here is this is
reaching out to your sisters
um
at some point you're gonna have to if
you want to preserve a relationship
which is what it sounds like you want to
it's letting them know that you love
them you're here
and um they may never come around and
say they were sorry
they may hold what happened forever
that's theirs to hold not yours
right um and maybe it's time that you
send them a handwritten letter to their
home
and say i miss my sisters and say dad's
um
dad's sudden death caught us all off
guard his arrangements with mom
were weird and were not in the best
interest of those who were his survivors
right weren't in the best interest of
his kids
but they were what they were i love you
guys and
i'm ready to have what we had and
all you can do at this point kyle is go
first
is to risk to be put the relationship
out there and they may reject you
brother they may say screw you we're
still not over it i don't think they
will
um i think you're a guy of a solid with
a solid heart and you're a great human
being so i don't think they're going to
but they might
and that's what this whole thing is
about is about risk right it's like
leaning forward
and heading into that here's a couple of
things
um number one if you're listening to
this
don't do a napkin on a wheel on a napkin
if you are separated from somebody and
it's not coming back
go through the legal processes and
if you are not living with somebody for
15 years make it official and go
and get your divorce get the stuff
illegally separated
so your poor kids don't lose their
relationship dealing with your mess
it's childish and it's ridiculous
it's just dumb okay
you can make a will we have a will here
through
um with relationship with mama bear
wills it's an inexpensive online will
here through ramsey solutions
you can go to daveramsey.com and we can
check in the show notes here
with mama beer get a will for crying out
loud give that to your kids for
christmas say hey kids i'm not going to
leave you high and dry if you have to
have a hard conversation
like kyle's going to have with his
sisters here's a couple of things
um just to think through
first plan your conversation don't just
show up don't just drop it like a
grenade know what you want to say and
where you want to get
and work backwards from there right if
you show up and you're emotionally
charged and you're going to have a hard
conversation
it just gets explosive and if you have
hard conversations and they start with
will you then somebody's instantly going
to get defensive and
now we're off to the races so
acknowledge things are going to be
uncomfortable if you have the
opportunity
set up a time and a place let people
know these things are coming
let them know that hey we need to have a
hard conversation about dad when you
have a hard conversation about a
relationship and this is for marriages
this is for kids this is for
anybody right this isn't just for kyle
and his sisters
but plan your conversation the second
thing is get in touch with your motives
and your goals for this hard
conversation
kyle said it best he wants his sister's
back
he had that relationship with them that
other people envied that other people
wish they had with their families
and then poof it was gone and it's gone
and i i don't want to talk bad
about your parents but it's bad it's
it's went sideways because
of poor planning of people not taking
care of their business
and leaving their children to deal with
things um
and so before you have the talk get in
touch with your motives some of you may
want to have hard conversation to say
our relationship has to change now
some of you have to have hard
conversations about you can no longer
talk to our daughter
like you do it's over now
but get in touch with yourself before
you talk to your family once you spend
time getting in touch with your motives
why are you having the conversation what
are the goals for this conversation
where where are we going to end up here
and then the third thing is
um is creating a safe space for this
dialogue
right i've gotten some feedback on
social media folks don't like
that i recommend people have hard
conversations in restaurants they think
that's
um a cowards way to do it that people
can't get emotional in a restaurant
um i like the neutral third party of it
all that's just me
but also i'm not prone to getting off
the rails emotionally
and some people do and that's okay
whatever it is create a safe space for
that dialogue right
get into a mindset that it's not about
you versus them
it's about us coming together it's about
us
joining forces to move forward with
whatever this is going to look like
whatever this is right
make it clear you care about other
people's feelings their motives their
needs
when people feel quote unquote safe in
your presence you give them permission
to actually speak
to actually be heard right stop
don't put this off get it done right get
it done have the conversation
oh just got this notice if you want to
go through the will
text will to 33789 will
33789 get the guide right on how to do a
will preparation checklist it's
ridiculous to not do it
okay but this isn't a will pitch um this
isn't what this is for
i want you guys to know how to have hard
conversations
go have them and get them done and
here's the other thing we're in
coming off a messy we're not coming off
at nothing we're
flat in the middle of a messy political
season of a messy pandemic
of a messy education mess economic mess
this is the season of hard conversations
plan them know why what are your goals
for these conversations what are your
motives
if your motives are just to hurt people
then shut your mouth just shut up
we have enough of that if your motive is
unity
and safety and coming together and even
if other people have to change
incredible awesome and then number three
create a safe space for the dialogue
kyle thank you so much for the call
brother um more on your dad
and then reach out to those sisters in a
written letter so they can hold it and
look at it and say
i want you guys back i miss my sisters
it's awesome thank you so much for the
call
um all right let's we're going to
totally change direction here i want to
leave the show on an up note
i want to go back to 1973
one of the legends one of the legends
guys who guy who wrote songs that lifted
people's spirits
stevie wonder in the extraordinary 1973
single
you are the sunshine of my life a single
so good it didn't even need an album it
just gave us like hey i'm putting this
song out it's that good
in this song he writes you are the
sunshine of my life
that's why i'll always be around you're
the apple of my eye
forever you'll stay in my heart i feel
like this is the beginning though i've
loved you for a million years
and if i thought our love was ending i'd
find myself drowning in my own tears
you are the sunshine of my life that's
why i'll always stay around
you're the apple of my eye forever
you'll stay
in my heart stevie that's what i'm
talking about
you are the sunshine of my life love it
this has been the dr john daloni show